die hamasterroristen haben es ganz
bewusst darauf angelegt unschuldige
Zivilistin und Zivilisten brutalst
möglich zu ermorden ich habe nicht den
Eindruck dass es Ziel der israelischen
Politik ist Zivilisten zu töten sondern
den Terror zu bekämpfen und was mich
beschämt ist vielleicht weniger dass ich
Frau Meer schämen muss irgendwo Deutsche
zu sein was mich schämt ist dass wir die
Sicherheit von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
jüdischen Glaubens in Deutschland nicht
mehr gewährleisten können dafür schäme
ich mich und ich fühle mich zum ersten
mal fremd in meinem eigenen Land weil
ich das niemals für möglich gehalten
[Musik]
hätte